Carrick is a prolific serial sex  offender  who preyed on women over a period of  many years  abusing his position as a police officer  and committing the most horrific  degrading crimes  he has devastated women's lives this is  a matter that we are truly sorry for we  have missed opportunities over time to  identify a pattern of abusive Behavior  we're truly sorry for the fact he  continued to be a police officer he  abused that poor that he had as a police  officer and and used that to control the  women who were his victims and I'm so  sorry that that will have prolonged the  suffering that those women have had and  I'm a total awe of them coming forward  now and seeing him to a successful  conviction